Heather is with us in Sacramento hi
Heather how are you hi David I am so
thankful to be talking to you how are
you better than I deserve
what's up I just wanted some advice on
how to talk to my ex-husband about money
he's a year ago I got full custody of
our daughter
and he I had filed for child support and
he got really abrasive with me and
they're just not wanting to have that
confrontation I dropped my request it's
been a it's been a year and I went back
and refiled because back in December
because he should support his child
hello right exactly
we have kids you know my daughter and
his daughter lives full-time and he pays
child support for his son and in
December my ex-husband texted me and
said he was going to claim our daughter
on this year's taxes he doesn't have
that right I know I know and so that
just kind of pokes it there and so I
went back and filed and he texted me
over the weekend saying hey I really
want to work on communication yada yada
I'm like okay I didn't we can you know
work on communication and so you may are
you remarried now no I I'm gonna commit
a relationship with my boyfriend uh for
help for how long we've been together
for two years
okay I've been separated from my husband
my ex-husband for three so I was you
know we worked together for him to see
our daughter he only sees her about four
times a year and so first thing Monday
morning he texted me asking hey you know
I really appreciate it some compassion
for my situation if I have to pay a set
amount each month I'm not even going to
make rent and this and that and
Total Money Makeover book yeah call the
wambulance child supports not 100% not
even in California he can pay his child
support make his rent neat right I'll
give him compassion he needs take care
of his dadgum kid he's a father right
well and he had he has five kids living
at times he's had two more kids since
we've separated and he wants to do a hey
let me know what you need as far as
money and start paying child support
right yeah this guy is a master
manipulator and he's self-centered as
crap I can tell that already yeah yeah I
got no use for people don't take care of
their kids man what's the best way to
approach that I don't think you're gonna
fix him no I'm not I don't think he's
gonna be happy I think I'm just gonna be
okay with him being unhappy okay that's
how I approach it I'm gonna be kind and
gentle but firm it's like you know you
brought this child into the world the
law says and morality says you should
take care of this child it really is not
rocket science Bubba
sign up and pay the bill that's how this
works and you know I'm sorry that it's
not you know you
he doesn't pay anything now hello so
maybe a big good idea if he just kind of
got practice and again taking care of
his kids it's a good idea that's why we
have this in the law because it's the
proper thing to do this is the Dave
Ramsey show